comme on l'a vu chez emmanuel macron
insisté sur le fait de continuer à
produire quelles solutions justement
pour poursuivre son activité
professionnelle pendant le confinement
la majorité des entreprises et des
salariés ont opté pour le télétravail
immersion dans un cabinet d'avocats en
région parisienne avec renault parquet
et solène gaudin souris ordinateur
dossier il a fallu tout rapatrier du
bureau au domicile pour continuer à
suivre les affaires en cours
m coria cette avocate en droit du
travail et confinement oblige elle a été
contrainte de se mettre au télétravail
grâce à internet son activité de conseil
se poursuit et clients sont très
concernés par les événements donc les
questions tournent beaucoup autour des
mesures de confinement et comment gérer
leurs salariés
néanmoins les dossiers habituel continue
à avancer et le confinement nous empêche
pas de travailler sur nos problématiques
traditionnels seules les audiences pour
des questions sanitaires sont ajournés
en droit du travail les juridictions
sont fermées donc cour d'appel conseil
de prud'hommes il n'y a pas d'audience
donc si des audiences étaient
programmées dans les deux trois
prochaines semaines n'auront pas lieu
on imagine que les juridictions
transmettront un calendrier avec les
dates de report si le télétravail
s'avère être une solution alternative
pour poursuivre son activité
il pourrait à terme provoqué une
saturation des réseaux internet et
ralentir l'activité à distance